there's a story that's breaking that
seems to be almost entirely on twitter
there are a few
just medium articles um but to the
degree that they're talking about
they're citing the twitter stuff so
we're gonna we're gonna go to twitter
here
basically 60 minutes we are told
the long-running um cbs i think
uh newshour show uh has been planning a
segment on d
transitioners that is people who have
transitioned um
to the other sex or gender depending on
who you're talking to
um and who have decided after some time
that it was a mistake that they are
going to detransition back into their
natal sex the sex that they were
born as um and uh as a result
of a lot of activist hubbub about this
it seems that
cbs may be actually rethinking
rethinking whether or not to do this and
that
that i find yet another piece of
dangerous evidence
that our journalism is being run by
narrative and by politics rather than
by um you know by actually trying to
discover what's true
so let's just um show a couple of the
the tweets and questions before talking
about this we have
um jennifer i will show this in just a
second zach
jennifer finney boylan who's a trans
woman and also a barnard professor and a
contributing opinion writer for the new
york times
who had 28 pieces in the new york times
in 2020 alone
so this is not an infrequent contributor
first introduced this to the world um
here
okay zachary um
tweet from march 20th there's going to
be a 60 minutes on d transitioners
she writes they asked me to be a talking
head and i said i prefer not to be part
of this story they said please
i said you ought to talk to tory peters
or at least someone
a-f-a-b since that's the focus they said
we'd really like you
jennifer phil uh finney boylan i said
i'm honored but i think this is a
terrible idea for a story why focus on
this small group of outliers
when you could focus on the struggles
and triumphs of so many other trans
folks
so just stepping out of this for a
moment trans is itself an
outlier group and trans has gotten a ton
of press in the last five and ten five
or ten years like
really more than any group of that size
warrants by the numbers and so for
people in
a tiny group of outliers who have been
getting much more press than their
numbers represent
to be complaining about people within
their group
who frankly may or may not be outliers
getting any press at all
seems like the best spin i can put on it
is it's the height of irony
it's the height of irony and it's also
uh
obviously duplicitous yes
so that would be a slightly less
generous interpretation it's a yes
slightly less generous but the simple
fact is the reason the
transitioners are forbidden and that
there would be pressure put on 60
minutes is
that the strongest argument for a
go slow approach let us leave
children to develop as they will um
and not leap to conclusions is that not
only
do does dysphoria so regularly
clear up on its own but that many people
who do
transition decide later it didn't solve
the issue
that they were hoping it would solve and
decide to transition back at which point
you can't fully transition back right
there are
downstream consequences of this and so
you know obscuring the awkward fact of
many people who have thought that they
wanted to transition and discover later
that they got bad advice or had
misunderstood things
um is really it's going to put people in
harm's way this story needs to be
covered because everybody who's thinking
of transitioning needs to consider the
possibility
that it isn't the solution for them yes
exactly as for instance abigail
schreier's excellent book needs to be
out there and available to people
and not be you know taken off of the
virtual shelves at amazon
um just two more blue check marks on
twitter
who are tweeting about this and who who
have cultural sway
we have chase trangio um at the you know
famous at least in some circles trans
lawyer at aclu
who quote tweets the boyle and tweet
thread that i just read the beginning of
saying this story is deliberately airing
at a time of dangerous assaults on trans
healthcare and trans lives
while we as trans people are harassed
and gaslight when we try to advocate for
our ability to just live
to just live i feel like i know who's
being gaslit and it's not
chase strangio right well that's the
core of gaslighting now isn't it yes it
is uh so
you know at a time of dangerous assaults
on trans health care and trans lives
that will always be the claim that will
always be the claim
and any group no matter how you define
that group
will always be experiencing something
they should not be experiencing because
that is the nature of existence
so there is nothing in here that is
falsifiable
and yet the entire thing is of a tone
that seems exactly wrong and actually
quite deceitful so just one more of
these
here we have someone um actually sorry
zach give me my screen back just for a
minute
so i can see this is someone who is the
former editor-in-chief of out
magazine and the former chief commercial
officer of teen
vogue teen vogue which seems to be one
of the
sort of spear points of a lot of this
madness
so the twitter account is pf bacardi
again quote tweets the original boylan
tweet thread saying the media illiteracy
around trans folks is nothing short of
dangerous
i hope the folks at 60 minutes know
there's a human toll to their
irresponsibility
each and every person affiliated with
selecting this narrative for air time
should be held
accountable held accountable the idea
that there are stories of
real people who have experienced real
pain and real harm
and their stories should not be told
is a remarkable claim yes and the
remarkable in the slightest veiled
threat
holding accountable people for telling
stories like for example
jesse single who has indeed
been uh falsely portrayed and you know
what would the term be demonized online
um
who has been uh quite good about
reporting
on all sides of the trans issue um
so i did want to add one other thing
here which
in the spirit of what we were talking
about last week
uh regarding candy and the idea that
there are certain things that are
that fit on a card yeah that actually
tell the story right it strikes me that
at the heart of the
issue of transition and detransition
is the hypocrisy of a movement and mind
you i'm not talking about trans people
you and i draw a distinction trans
activists are the ones who have become
so
troubling and frightening but
if trans rights are human rights right
if the right to transition is a human
right
then surely people who have already
transitioned
also have the right to transition and
have the right to have
that story told right so my point is if
the only people on earth
who don't have the right to transition
are people who've already done it
something is off right and if those who
are advocating for trans people
are the ones who are ruling out the
discussion
then they are telling you what they're
up to right this is a one-way phenomenon
from their perspective
yes right yes and uh we need to
recognize that
and um we need to frankly stare down the
threats because
you know there is the the group of
people who have decided
that transition is what they need to do
and there is an
infinitely large group of people who
have yet to make such a decision
um and many of them are children they
are easily influenced and they have a
right to have normal development unfold
before
irreversible decisions are made on their
behalf exactly
and you know it's not it's not that
everything in this landscape
is clear-cut right for those
extremely rare people extremely rare
people
who really would describe themselves to
you and
some of them have described themselves
to us as having been born in the wrong
body
the earlier they would be allowed to
transition the more likely
their their their understood and deeply
felt
brain sex would be could be come to
become in accord with
the body that they are then um allowed
to transition into
that is a tiny fraction of of
one percent of humanity a tiny tiny
fraction of probably a hundredth
of one percent um for the
vast majority of people regardless of
how they view themselves how comfortable
they are in their skin
whether or not they're gay straight by
whatever
the vast majority of people who do not
end up feeling that the way that they
must live in the world forever after
is as the sex that they were not born to
messing with development is permanent
and tragic and
going to result in the things like
infertility mental health problems
and other physical problems like bone
density loss
yeah and sexual dysfunction and sexual
dysfunction yes
all and and that's and that's an
incomplete list yeah so
you it is it is not it is not the right
of a tiny tiny tiny number of people
to change development for everyone else
and in fact
it's and and and having children have
this
thrust on them because they say
something in the spirit of
childhood where they're exploring
identity because that's what childhood
is
is should be criminal it should be
criminal it should be
um i would also um point out
that somehow we have been lured into a
conversation
in which everything downstream of the
concept of trans
is taken to be sacred and
this doesn't make any sense we have said
repeatedly that
too many cultures have trans as some
role ancient cultures for us to imagine
that this is some
new invention or that it is inherently a
disorder
however this is not the same thing as
saying
pharmaceutical transition and surgical
transition
is ancient it isn't and so to the extent
that we are talking about
who has surgery available to them how
early in life
when can we disrupt a developmental
process
in order to you know to ostensibly
help you these are not simple matters
right and they are very different from
the right to live as you would
right yes right the ability to be
surgically altered as you would
is not a human right right we have not
declared it such
right there are surgeries you can't go
get right so
this is not one of those things and
we need to stop pretending it is
compassion for people is
important and the recognition that trans
is something
real and ancient is important that is
very different from
pharmaceutical and surgical alteration
[Music]